hire me to be your step decorator I'm
gonna decorate hey guys it is Wednesday
here on its grace for once every ones
that are so dumb it is June which means
I guess it's kind of officially
summertime and a lot of you will be
either finishing school or have finished
school and you'll be having a lot more
free time I will be spending my time
trying to construct sentences that have
sensible to them and are not just any
way because of the internet we all get
bored really quickly so I've come up
with 25 things that you can do this
summer to avoid boredom push someone
into a pool friend or stranger but try
to go for an elder or an animal that can
swim try and put a scuba mask on a swan
and then be like hey Swan do you know
what you are a swan dive idiot put a
dead fish somewhere in your friend's
closet don't tell them they'll figure it
out
switch out on your family members cereal
and chips get them real good you just
open that box of Lucky Charms and
there's [ __ ] Doritos in there you
[ __ ] idiot what kind of world do you
live in these things are really like
activities as much as they are just
pranks and the main things that's okay
pranks are an activity make a t-shirt
that says pants pronounce all words that
have a Q&A you in the word as quit for
instance let's go ante quit shopping you
have a question that one actually works
here this is not a good one buy yourself
an ice cream and stand in public I let
the ice cream fall when you try and eat
it and then start crying and see if
someone buys you a new ice cream
Victorville cocktail using at least one
condiment put a dildo on a side table
doing someone else's party and just see
what
hopefully no one starts using it well
it's that kind of party
make a sock puppet named on fire or cat
queef tag me on your Instagram photos
make a terrarium and put teeny-tiny
little people in them you can see how to
do that on DIY damn it with Joslyn
Hughes they do sell teeny-tiny people in
a lot of varieties
mamrie made a video called teeny-tiny
new deep something just maybe just new
york Toby's just buying teeny-tiny naked
people make up a song but you have to
use the phrase titty taint or titty
panty I guess they write a play starring
John Legend John Travolta Jon Bon Jovi
and my brother John I have a brother
named John this was just one long
activity to get you to know that I have
a brother named John make a pillow out
of a t-shirt a nice creative activity go
to the thrift store with a friend and
you guys have to buy each other's outfit
and then you have to wear them out in
public all day
think about it get a group of friends
together to watch movie Cameron Lee wait
and then when you turn it on turn it off
right away and say you know what I can
wait and then go lock yourself in the
bathroom see what happen make a slip and
slide out of trash bags and olive oil
figure it out just try and get someone
to let you christen their baby I wanted
to do this so bad the idea of pouring
big water on a baby is just like so fun
finger paint a mural with a message that
says this mural has a message run into
an elevator fart and get out of there
before the door closes welcome to the
wrong movie theater and scream I don't
want to alarm any of you but someone has
[ __ ] in the back of this theater [ __ ] on
the floor make a tent and fill it with
potential in your pants don't ya
barbecue something that's also just
an activity both through drive-through
on a Segway this one might cost you some
money to rent the Segway and or buy it
because you just wanted one personal
world to segue YouTube search all of
people confused actually haven't done
that yet so let me know it goes well
that was 25 but the I wanna add this up
to go to my book okay this guy's look
calm there you go there 25/26 maybe
activities that you can do it this
summer so you won't be bored Grace's
guidebook